so actually are you more excited about
the release of the last exorcism to than
you were for the first at all that's
that's a toughy okay both have been
mind-blowing um you know the last
exorcism part 1 was my breakout film and
it was such an incredible opportunity to
have that moment and have a film that
started out almost as an independent
film get such international acclaim
audiences came out in droves I got
nominated for a spirit award and an MTV
Award it was just it was it was huge and
now to have the opportunity to do part
two and two step back into my doc
martens uh bet it metaphorically uh it's
been it's been really incredible I mean
as you remember from the first I play
Nell Sweetzer who is this vulnerable
sheltered girl she doesn't even know
what an ipod is and he or she is thrown
into New Orleans thrown into Mardi Gras
there's temptation everywhere and she
has to choose between good and the
ultimate evil and so why should we be
excited about part two tell us tell us
we're sort of the audience can become
excited about the second part too well
the devil never has a last exorcism uh
you're dealing with evil that has no
boundaries so you know part two is great
because it has spooks and scares or you
least expect them I mean in dealing with
the devil he sets up for now so
methodically firsts and things she's
never been privy to like makeup and a
first kiss and friends and a boyfriend
and then very carefully takes each and
every one of them away and in that are
the scares and in that are the shocks
and there's an ending that literally
it's something only Eli Roth could pull
off it's such it's such a it's such a
twist I can't spoil anything because it
wasn't it's I think audiences will be
really really shocked
you